Hello, hello, hello, sorry I had to loop because my food
literally got here like 10 minutes before I was supposed to
start the stream And I was like, oh shit, and I was like,
um, yum yum during the loop Um, by me and now I have several
updates to give you guys First off, the most important
update I might be sick very soon You guys might be like,
Toki, how do you know that?
Are you like, can you tell the future or some shit?
Well, um, I could tell because when I woke up, this is
always the sign where i'm like oh i'm gonna be sick soon i
can feel it um but uh basically uh i woke up and i felt my
my throat being sore and you know that's like the first sign
where you're like oh no this is gonna get worse soon so
she's psychic she can tell the future burner she's a witch
but yeah so i feel the sore throat hitting right now so um
that's when you know it's gonna get worse uh next couple and
because of that i realized i ran out of like over the
counter um over the counter yeah i got orange juice right
now i order orange juice with my with my sandwich um but
then like so then i ordered like dayquil um uh on uber eats
and then it's really funny because i think this is a new
thing but you need an id now if you're like ordering if
you're ordering medication off the Because I was like, what
if they're like, oh, remember to, uh, you have to meet the,
meet the guy, delivery guy.
So you can scan, they can scan your ID.
And I mean, like, I guess like too many chills.
I guess like, cause my, the one I got was like maximum
strength.
So you gotta make sure I'm not like under 18.
And I'm like some child trying to get high on pain meds or
some shit.
So yeah.
So I got the X maximum strength dayquil.
Just to be sure, you know, I'm, I'm like starting early
because I can tell that it's, I can tell it's coming.
So I was like, if I start early, then I can stop it maybe
before it happens.
You know, it's like a premonition.
It's like final destination.
I'm being like, stop.
We got to leave.
We got to leave before the virus comes or maximum strength.
um so yeah i may or that final medication i may or may not
get very sick in the next couple of days which sucks because
we have a lot of very fun streams uh for this week so uh for
this year for 2026 i went on like a super um like a soup
like 2026 would be like my biggest push basically because i
want to push for a million subscribers so i went like super
hardcore mode the last couple of days with my manager and i
like making plans and stuff for this year and everything
like setting stuff up um so we do have a lot of fun things
in the works uh for the next couple of months um yeah it's a
2026 push all right another thing i want to talk about dad
update um you guys do not follow me on twitter i took dad to
a pet store um i think like two days ago because i wanted to
um his nails were getting too long so now it's just like you
know what it's spa day so i decided to give him a little spa
day at the um at my local pet store and um while it's there
i bought him a john ass fucking bone because i thought it
was really funny i thought there was a bigger version of
this too i was like hmm she's too big i was like i i i
attempted i was like i should buy a size smaller than that
so the one i bought was not even the biggest bone i need you
guys to know that it's not even the biggest one they had in
stock i went down a size because i was like maybe this one's
a little too big i'll buy a smaller one and this was for
those who don't follow me on twitter let me grab the picture
um what i had to save it off of twitter this is the smaller
size bone.
This one is the smaller size bone.
And I fucking love that I like gave it.
Like I bought it and I went outside and just gave it to him.
And then he and then he's like, and then he like, he was
like so happy.
And then he like picked it up and then walked away with it.
I was like, wait, come back.
I was like, it was just tracking them.
It was just like, I leave now.
Goodbye.
yeah he's like goodbye goodbye mother i leave now and he was
away water water and he walked away water water he literally
walked so far dude he actually was like ready to leave me he
was like he was ready to fucking leave he's like i know the
way home goodbye mother he got what he needed he's like
finally It's over.
I got what I want.
Papa, thank you.
The super chat.
Thank you.
Yay, my ocean sick.
Let's effing go.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Mr. Broken ball.
Dragon Ease is just donkey eating 10 minutes before his
stream.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Hey guys.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Since you sadly won't be streaming tomorrow.
I know we're on birthday then.
Are you feeling good enough for a happy birthday song for me
in advance?
Thank you for the super chat.
Hey guys.
What do you mean?
I am streaming.
tomorrow.
We gotta go.
I don't know.
Are you trying to protect the future?
Are you trying to say something's gonna happen to me
tomorrow?
What's gonna happen to me tomorrow?
What do you mean?
Anyway, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear.
Hey guys.
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah.
Happy birthday.
something we don't i'm like what do you mean on my schedule
it says i'm going to stream tomorrow what do you mean i
probably won't be streaming tomorrow
i like you don't stream tomorrow
don't come to school tomorrow um does she know oh yeah so um
another update uh dad update so he got Super overwhelmed at
the pet store because I like let him walk around a little
bit And he was like he was and like he got a little toy
during the spa day because I paid extra I was like, you know
what you get everything today dad.
It's not your birthday, but I'm feeling generous So like you
basically you saw a little bandana on him.
So you got a little free bandana.
Oh, it wasn't free It was like fucking $80.
The spa day was $80 but they throw in like they threw in a
bandana and a fucking toy for him um for quote-unquote free
it's okay it's 80 canadian dollars
um so yeah they threw in a free quote-unquote free bandana
and toy because they're like i can't believe we we suckered
it into an 80 spot anyway so so uh he was carrying his
little toy around the pet smart and he was so fucking
overwhelmed he was like looking around he's like he was like
walking around looking around trying to smell everything
he's like oh my god oh my god there's so many smell i'm so
excited oh my god and then he stopped in the middle it's
like i'm just gonna pee here now and it's like and i'm like
what the dust is like he's just like he's like oh oh oh my
god oh my god there's so many oh oh oh oh that's too much i
was like no the thing is before i the spot it i let him i
like took him on a walk i i like took him on a walk so he
like to make sure he went to the bathroom before i told him
to the groomers so yeah everything is his territory now yeah
he peed in the fucking middle of the store like it wasn't
like in the aisle or anything it was literally in the middle
of it and so i was like how do you still have so much pee
inside you I thought you had to get all out.
Yeah, so they're always ready to go.
So, yeah, he had to he peed in the middle of it, and he's
just like, okay, I'm done.
Dad does not make an accident.
He pees where he needs to.
Maddie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, yeah, the entire store is his now.
So, that was my dad update for the year.
After Yaf.
Thank you for the super chat.
Magenta super.
Thank you.
Happy New Year, Doki.
Sunday was my birthday.
Can you wish me a sign up file up before the rage bay?
Of course I can.
Thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
Join me soon.
You're happy.
Happy birthday, dear.
Yaf.
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah!
You get like bilingual.
Happy birthday.
Yeah.
Thank you again.
The magenta super.
Thank you.
um so that was my dad update another update um uh i got a
new haircut well i didn't get a new haircut literally just
said chop half of the hair off because it was too long i
haven't had a haircut in a long ass time but my usual i
usually go to a an asian salon because like um i don't know
i just i guess like you know because i'm asian and my hair
is asian um i prefer going to like an asian because like I
feel like they know what to do with my hair um so but uh not
today so I think it was like yesterday I went to a western
hair salon because the Asian hair salon uh was closed on
that day and I was like I really need to cut my hair it's
been way too long and it's way long I hate I hate super long
hair only because um it's very hard to manage and um hey
guys thank you to chat thank you thank you and um and it's
just like you know like i just it's just not convenient for
me i usually have it like on shoulder length but like now
it's like it was really long like it was like my back
basically because i have to i it's like i haven't had a
haircut in a while because i was so fucking busy and you
know if you're a woman being in a hair salon takes like at
least one hour depend just for a haircut by the way like all
you women girls you know what i'm saying and then like so it
takes like at least an hour just for like um just for a
haircut and like blow dry or something like that if you want
to dye your hair because they're like you want to dye your
hair and i was like no that's fine like um my my roots are
now at the path like like where my eyes are like that's
where my roots are because i was just like no it's okay i
really want to sit on a chair for two to three hours today i
was just like um no that's all right i really don't want to
sit on the chair for that long um that day so i was just
like um it's okay i'll come back next time but also i just
wanted to test the salon out too because like you know it
was a western hair salon so like not my usual asian hair
salon i usually go to like a chinese or Korean hair salon
for my haircuts um anyway so uh so I you know it was also by
the way it was also like a hundred like almost like a
hundred dollars too for guys okay so I don't know men have
it really easy when it comes to like barber shop because
they're like choo choo choo here's like $15 um for women
hair salon it's like cut hair shampoo uh blow dry hundred
dollars and like by the way it was like 80 was the base
price too so yeah so it was like yeah and it's like pretty
normalized for us I don't fucking know why yeah so it was
like a hundred dollars and I was like okay um anyway hey but
the girl who worked on my hair apparently won a lot of
awards so I really that happy with my hair cut but i don't
think she works on asian people because like it's like
really weird so um um i guess it's like a western hair like
style for hair so i was just like i was like oh i want you
to thin my hair um i want you to thin my hair because it's
like i grow hair a lot so she was like yeah you have a lot
of hair it's like yeah no you have a lot so i was like can
you like thin my hair and uh i just like i want to cut my
hair like i want to like shorten it so like i showed her
like i want it to be this length and then and yet she didn't
even get it to that length she like kept it long like still
like sort of long but like she didn't cut a lot off but like
i said i had a lot of hair growing down so i was just like i
need you to cut like this much but she's still also like it
wasn't as much as i wanted at that point i was just
um the thing is um she like it's weird i don't know how this
okay it's like it's like uh it's like flat okay okay i'll
draw it out i'll try it when she cut it i looked at it i was
like that's i'm not used to it but i guess like for western
hairstyle that's how they usually do it so it was like okay
so i'm drawing this out on paint right now so like when she
cut it it was like sharp ass like like a line
Like Like it's a line Okay I'll do like a comparison Of what
what like an Asian Hair styles usually would do versus like
I guess like a Western hairstylist Because I was not used to
that Like she did this as if it's like a normal Thing and I
was like what the so it's like This like it's like a line
But then like if you go to an Asian hair salon long it's
like like this okay i'll show you guys it's like this you
know okay that's the head and that's so it's like it's not
just a line like do you guys understand what i'm talking
about it's not just a line it's like so it was like yeah
like it was so weird because i looked in the mirror I was
like, why is it okay?
Like, yeah, okay, I'll give you guys a side-by-side.
I have to redraw it, though, because I just saved over it.
So, it's like, like, front and back, too.
It was so fucking weird.
But I was just like, I don't know if we can fix this.
I don't think you're used to.
I don't think you're used to, like, cutting Asian hairstyle.
I don't think I don't want to I don't want to risk it
because let's like like I know I don't go outside much but
then when I do go outside I don't want anything to be like
weird so so this is like the western hairstyle and this is
like the Asian hairstyle we're like you know what I mean
it's like an Asian hairstyle it's like like um there's like
I guess like dimensions to it but then like the western
hairstyle is just like like just just get a scissors and go
and then just cut
yeah so like so this would be the western style yeah it's
like this is yeah this is like the Asian hairstyle too yeah
like this it was just so weird I'm not used to that at all
so no but the thing is she like had her all her awards
displayed too she had like all her awards displayed and
apparently she's like she was like master three hairstylists
um um and uh and it's like it like she had her base price
was 80 to be fair i just booked like whoever was free like i
didn't really care who i got i was like um i want an
appointment at this time and like whoever's free i'll get it
you know i've always gone to an asian hair salon and like
never had to be specific on like how they cut my hair and it
always is like this so i was just like yeah master three is
her grandmaster is her top five and then she had all her
awards put like displayed at the front of the mirror and it
was like oh number one hairstyle like 2025 number one
hairstylist at this hair salon i was like oh okay so the
price was like worth it you know like so um so i was like
okay so i guess i guess the it's it's all right like and
then she's like oh and then she's like do you want to get
your hair dials like i can match it and the thing is when
i'm at my eight like she's like oh i can match it to your to
the color um and just do your roots and stuff i was just
like oh and i i felt like a I had like red flags for it
because in my Asian hair salons, if my roots get too much,
if I like don't get my hair dyed like in time to cover the
roots and the roots spread too far, my Asian hairstylist
would be like, we need to dye the whole thing.
Like it's better to dye the whole thing.
So there's no mismatch of colors.
So I was just like, so then I'm like, that's weird that
you're like, oh, we'll just fix, I can just do the roots and
I can match this color.
And I was like,
i was just like i i don't can you though i'm not very
confident that you can but like yeah i'll definitely come
back i'll i was just like yeah yeah i'll come back i'll come
back to do it next time i just yeah sure yeah questioning
your master three hair sounds because i've never because
usually it would just do the whole head just to make sure
that the colors fully there's no like mismatch of colors if
I haven't gotten dyed in a long time so and that's what it's
usually been since I've been growing up so it's just so
weird that she I I've never had a I don't know I don't I'm
not a hairstylist so I I'm not sure like if um if that's
natural thing or if I'm just getting scammed like they just
wanted me to pay more but um I was just worried that she
won't actually match the colors.
Because I was like, do you really know my actual color of my
hair dye?
Because I don't know.
I don't know if you actually do.
A, Z, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm so happy to be able to catch up on VODs and watch this
stream.
Could I get belated for these?
Complenos for my birthday.
Thank you.
Thank you, the super chat AZ.
I don't know how to sing happy birthday in Español, but I
know I sing Merry Christmas.
Feliz Navida.
Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum, that AZE.
Whoa!
I want to wish you a happy birthday.
Happy birthday, bum, bum, bum, bum, nah, nah, nah, yeah,
happy birthday, yeah, I'm not close enough.
So, yeah, most likely I won't come back.
It's just weird.
I did not like, I did not like that she did this.
It's just, it, it's like a straight line.
It's so fucking weird.
But, like, my hair is so long.
It's not like it's a bob cut or something.
But it feels like a nap.
I don't know.
For me, it's, like, super unnatural.
Like, it just feels so straight.
It was just like.
It, I don't, yeah.
It's just too, like, when I looked in the mirror, I was
like, I was just like, oh, my God.
Why is it so straight?
and i've never had that before like i've never had like i
just i just never had a hairstyle like that because it's
always been like this where where it's like layered and it's
like po po po po po like it's like like you know little
triangles you know at the bottom like it's not like like i
like yeah
It's the best I can describe it.
I'm definitely going to go back to my Asian hair salon.
I was like debating about it too.
I was like, do I just wait another day?
And I was like, no, my hair.
My hair is way too fucking long.
I cannot handle this right now.
Oh, another update.
Another update.
I got another email.
That's what I know.
This guy definitely doesn't watch me.
I got another email from him.
All right.
Anyway, this is where I'm last.
Even my manager was like, bro, he's back.
I was like, he's back?
Just no, no.
For a recap of what the fuck I'm talking about.
There's this guy that's been sending me emails since the
last week.
And because he's been trying to get me to reach out to this
other VTuber who have zero connection with.
For some fucking reason, he thinks like me and her are like
friends or some shit.
And he's been trying to get me to reach out to her and be
like, Hey, there's this fucking creepy ass stalker that's
been trying to get a hold of you.
Like, I don't know why the fuck he thinks I'm the one.
I think he's like, I don't know.
Maybe he's been messaging a lot of people too.
But like, this email is directly to me.
So I don't know if he's like typing several different
emails.
No, you're like, can you block it?
But the thing is, it's like, at this point, it's like
interesting.
guy so like it's like i don't i didn't block him because at
this point i'm like curious what he's gonna send me next um
so so anyway new email like his new email was like hey can
you ask this vtuber to stay up tonight because i'm gonna
play this song and this song is like my message to her and
i'm like how the like I guess like there's different answers
so it's like like I guess he thinks like when he plays this
song she will feel it in her soul or some shit and he's like
um it's like oh this is my song my message to her and he's
like she'll know that I'm talking to her and she's like and
then this is okay this life if she not knows that I wanted
to go out with her that's great but she doesn't least hint
to her that would love to and bro no he does he thinks he's
like the fucking main character of this like the fucking
story or so shit like he thinks he's in the fucking matrix
i'm like oh my god bro please she is not interested if you
have to reach out to me to to try and get in touch with this
person who have zero association with and she has not been
responding to your emails or text she is not interested if
you have been blocked by this supposed vtuber then that is
your sign bro stop please like go outside
please go outside thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you spamming email soccer behavior is one thing but
not watching me that's where i draw the line thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you um lolly thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you yeah so so anyway i don't
know if he does see this stream like if he does watch this
stream like i think he should have got the hit when i've not
replied back the last week i have not sent back a single
reply and he's still at it he's shooting shots at everyone
um bro i thought this was a clip but it's live it's still
happening but i said thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you simple minded thank you the super chat thank you
thank you joki promise me if you start sending bad pictures
it's great thank you for the super chat thank you that's
what i'll block him guys if he that's where i will start
blocking him because at that point yeah no bro you've
crossed the line At first it was content.
Now it's not.
Now you need help.
I mean, you've always needed help, but like at that point,
you really need help.
Like, yeah, it's not.
Yeah, Chicano.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just to clarify, it's not even directed to you, but them
trying to get you to contact another V2 to convey their
feelings for him.
That's, yes, that's the, that's what's crazy about.
it like like i don't know her i i don't follow her but yet
she thinks like me and her are like best friends or some
shit so i'm like how like i'm just like where are you at
this point in your life that you're you like deluded
yourself and you're thinking that i know every vtuber in
existence like just because i'm a vtuber i know other
vtubers apparently so please please if you are watching this
please get some help because this is not normal.
This is absolutely not normal, bro.
I really highly encourage you to please get some help or
talk to someone about this.
Not me.
I'm just a virtual anime girl on the internet here to make
people laugh.
I'm not your therapist.
Talk to someone, but not me.
Talk to someone that you
I am a content creator I
yeah so anyway just winded up thank you guys on that I was
very I did tell you guys if I did get another email I will
let you guys know and I did end up getting another email
anyway to the actual game we're gonna be playing agree this
is the new flavor of the month for vtubers it's basically a
rage bait games rage bait game and a lot of viewers love
watching rage bait but I will not get rage baited I played
all so many rage bait games and this is the and I've built a
tolerance to rage bait I built a tolerance to rage bait and
I am strong I will refuse to get rage baited as long as I
agree to the terms of service we will not get rage baited.
God, so only send your emails to get caught with VTubers.
You do.
No.
Like, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I also got another email about, like, okay, it's fucking
weird.
Do not stalk VTubers, guys.
It's weird.
But, like, I also got another email from, like, this other
VTuber, and they're like, whoa, are you talking about this
guy?
It was not about this guy by the way but then they're like
this guy is like a serial liar or some shit and like um like
like just don't stalk people in general that is fucking
creepy please get some help um um anyway so um like they
were like they send me an email and no it's my business
email guys like and then they assume that i'm the only one
that reads my business email and not my fucking staff team
like i've had people email email my business email thinking
they're talking to me and when they're also talking to my
staff as well so anyway and then this guy apparently was
like lying to like a bunch of like really small content
creators like this different guy by the way this is a
different guy where like i worked with this guy to create my
skin suit and they're like And then apparently this guy was
telling very small VTubers that they were like, he was like,
yeah, I was the one that gave her the concept to make her
new skin suit, the bounty hunter one, to make her bounty
hunter skin suit, a tomboy skin suit.
And I'm like, who the fuck is this guy?
I was just like, what?
Bro, only two people knew about the conceptual art of my
bounty hunting one.
And it was me and my manager while I was trying to figure
out how it should look like.
Bro thinks he's part of the team.
And then apparently this guy was claiming...
that like, that I consulted with him to how the skin suit
was gonna look like.
When we joined the behind the scenes, I was like fucking
telling you guys about how hard it was to figure this out
with me and my manager trying to figure out.
Like, yeah, I was like, I was like, I was like, I was like,
what the fuck do you mean?
The only third party studio that worked on my debut was
literally like the whole giant videos for it.
But that was after the Bounty Hunter's skin suit model was
done.
Yeah, he like self-inserted himself, like, into, like, the
story that he made up being, like, I was the one that gave
her the idea that it should be a tomboy.
And I'm like, bro, everyone knew I was going to make a
tomboy model.
Like, like...
That's so...
It was like stolen value.
He believed in the lies so hard.
Yeah.
So like this random VT was asking me like, oh, did you
actually work with this guy?
Or, and like how like he knows me.
And I'm like, who the fuck?
Okay, I'll say it.
Who the fuck is Matt?
They're like, they're like, do you know Matt by any chance?
And I'm like, who the fuck is Matt?
Matt.
Like, no, I do not know.
Nobody on my staff team is named Matt.
Like,
yeah, Matt Pat from the game three, bro.
It was me, Matt.
Do you get to give this super chat?
Thank you.
The VTubing Cena is wild, bro.
Yeah, I know.
I was just like, I'm like, thank you.
Like, who the fuck is this guy claiming to work for me?
That's just a theory.
A game theory.
All right.
Anyway.
And then, like, they were like, we were unable to vet any of
his stories.
I mean, if he doesn't show any proof, that means none of his
stories are real.
Because, like, you would think that, like, if he was so
excited, like, he got to work with me.
That he would have a screenshot.
of him telling me that it's like you should have a tomboy
model and be like oh my god i guess i should if you if they
do not provide any evidence slash screenshots of all these
lies that he's claiming of then most likely they are lies
it's because he's signing nda or some shit yeah but if it
debuted already then you can show it like that working for
you was his theory his game theory uh raccoon thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you hey doky it was my
birthday yesterday can you belated happy birthday from me of
course raccoon of course happy birthday to you happy
birthday to you happy birthday dear raccoon happy birthday
to you yeah happy birthday
Anyway, story time's over.
It's gaming for real.
So, um, as a fellow, Matt, the council of Matt, this owns
this creep.
Council, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
By the way, Matt's a different guy.
Matt's a different guy, apparently.
The other one, I won't say his name because he's still
emailing me.
So, um, so like, um, if he does something, like, beyond
creepy than what he is doing now, then I will, like, say his
name out.
But, like, for now, the other guy is not Matt.
this the one that was lying about working for me is matt
yeah this is like since the other guy is an ongoing
situation uh i won't reveal his name yet um this is the only
way to and like eventually he will stop if you shame him
enough he will stop for those who are like why are you why
are you giving him attention or give like enabling this i am
not i am shaming him because that's they can they'll learn
shaming people like shaming people works and this is um this
is actually how you can get them to stop because i've had
that scenario before i i talked about the memory stream um
but like i've had um no that's the thing i've had this
happen before and i did the thing where i just ignored it
this was before people in the memory stream heard this story
before but um um i've had a very similar situation and it
was like directed at me and it was back in the barth night's
time so back before corporal and everything and basically
they didn't stop until i publicly shamed them on social
media and then they stop so like it gets to a point where
you literally cannot ignore them and it's the only way it
gets them to fucking realize that it is bad like it's wrong
yeah so it's why i do it it's the only way all right anyway
also another thing i heard about this game um is that uh is
that basically it can this game depends on your rng and
basically it can go from two hours or ten hours just
depending on how fucked uh how fuck your luck is to green to
the terms of service.
So we're gonna see how this goes, guys.
Yeah, live and die by RNG.
I've seen VTubers take two hours.
I've seen VTubers take 20 hours.
So let's hope that it doesn't get to that point.
Rick, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you buzzed like it?
Cause you're keeping this goes.
Infinity and beyond.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Just want my favorite chat to kiss you.
No way.
Am I keeping this to myself?
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
I hope I brought you lots of luck.
But thank you again for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Start game.
Let me know if Sound.
I don't know if Sound Guy is alive, but if he's alive, let
me know if the sound is okay.
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
The whole point is to just agree to terms of service.
Oh, okay, I was gonna say it.
Um, where is it?
What?
Where is it?
It should be green, right?
Is it not green?
Okay, disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree,
disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree,
Disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree,
oh there you go, oh my god, that's how they got you, I was
just looking for green.
All right.
You're just going to consider it to be hidden feature that
you may share it as you are discovering it.
Use your shell.
But it just says, oh, agree.
Yeah!
Okay, I figured it out.
Um, agree?
Okay, I just assumed that, um, I just closed all of that.
Wow.
No more, I'll eventually agree to the terms of service,
guys.
Oh, oh, shit!
That's okay.
That's fine.
Okay, they got me there.
They got, they got me there.
It's okay, we, we got, okay.
surely they oh my god pachinko oh my god I told you guys
it's all are you okay okay it's okay how many can I get oh
my god pachinko I said I didn't get rage baited I still have
to go down the score down those long TOS page that most
games have I think they give me the super chat they can
think okay but at least the terms of service on regular
games don't take Don't take two plus hours, guys.
At best, Disney Plus has my soul, but at least I can watch
my shows.
Okay, here we go.
Let's see.
Oh.
Come on, come on, come on.
It's just like herding sheep.
Is it?
How am I?
Oh, yeah, I'm still on the TOS.
How is he supposed to sound balance all of this?
All right.
down the sound.
I don't know if I can turn down the what?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
It's like whack-a-mole.
Oh my god.
Okay, wait, wait.
I'll just stay here.
Oh my god.
It's like actually like whack-a-mole.
Come on.
You'll come over here, right?
Yes.
Alright, there you go.
Alright, this game is training us when boss gets so good,
companies will have paladins.
It's just a reset or pass.
At least we know i'm not ai what and
you can now agree with this button please find the agree
text oh
oh my god oh
agree there you go agree we did it there it's right there
it's right there it's right i found it it's right there.
Okay.
This is Japanese.
Just read Japanese.
Don't get me that hard.
Okay.
Yeah, I can.
There you go.
Oh, Oh my god, oh my god, okay.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you kidding me?
Are you- I'm not rage-baited.
I'm not rage-baited.
I'm just yelling excitedly about stuff.
I'm just very excited.
Oh.
Okay, agree.
I'm just very excited.
It's not rage-bait if I'm just very happy.
What?
Yes.
i really checked did you read yes i did you didn't check the
blast of thinking right i read it carefully again do you
agree yes oh my god yes okay there you go agreed all right
agree agree oh don't okay agree agree it's fine we're
pachinkoing again agree agree agree it's just a little bit
pachinko won't hurt nobody okay there you go agree i agree
to sell my soul as long as i beat the game what the fuck no
oh oh oh
okay okay it's fine it's fine
No, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
There you go.
Agreed.
All right.
We're halfway.
What the fuck?
There's no way.
There's, okay, it's here.
It's right here.
They can't mess with me.
I'm so locked in.
If I don't meet my cursor.
Okay, here.
I'm so locked in.
Okay.
Here.
Okay, here.
All right.
Boom, boom, boom.
Boom, boom.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Boom, boom, boom.
Boom, boom.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Boom, boom, boom.
Oh, my God.
Which one was it?
right guys i i went down for so long i don't even remember
which one it was this one right number two okay all right
let's go in there oh oh boom boom yeah second boom to the
left regarding fried
where's the agree oh my god Okay, okay.
Okay.
That's where it is.
Okay, I realize where it is.
And then...
There.
Alright, we made it.
We made it.
That's okay.
It's a very long time limit.
Um, masquerade, welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
All right.
What the?
Oh.
Where is he?
Where?
I saw it.
It's right there.
Where?
Yeah.
Oh, I saw it.
I saw it too.
Oh, my God.
He never moved.
What?
No, you gotta be kidding me.
Oh my god, this is my last one.
Oh, agree.
Makes it extremely...
Dogs, dogs, and sorry, apology, okay.
Guys, I'm gonna phone a friend.
Which compound is mainly responsible for tearing when
cutting onions, guys?
guys I'm phoning a friend guys guys I'm I'm phoning a friend
D is it is it a Allison B carbonic acid C glutamic acid or D
cysteine sulfoxide calling a friend we allow it it's D is
that our final answer.
D for Doki.
D as an A.
Wait, what?
Or in a small way to kill Tommy, like correct number and
position.
number and wrong position.
Okay.
Oh, it's four digits okay okay i will do four okay correct
number and position okay two is correct so okay so two okay
wait wait wait okay we got two how about five two
one wait let's do five six okay Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Five, six, seven, eight.
Okay.
Five and one.
It's five and one.
Okay.
Zero, two, nine, five.
Oh, zero.
It's zero, two, five.
Okay.
Zero, two, five.
Wait.
What?
Wait, no.
Zero.
Wait, okay, wait, wait Zero Oh wait, no, it's nothing
Nothing is right JK No zero, I was looking at the wrong
thing Um, five One Five, one and two are correct Okay Um Uh
Two two One five Oh, wait, no.
2-2-5-1.
What?
Okay,
it's...
What?
Is this correct number in position?
It doesn't tell you the...
Oh, my God.
One is always the second one.
There's no...
0, 2, 9, or 5.
0, 2.
I'm, I'm fucking losing it.
I, I am losing it.
I am fucking losing it right now.
I am.
Oh, guys, guys, we have 80 seconds.
Just fucking throw in numbers.
I'm so not booed, though.
1643.
Oh, wait,
wait!
164 something!
6184?
6184.
Oh!
Wait, 618 something!
Wait, 30 seconds!
What is it?
3!
Oh my god, 618.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
10 seconds!
No!
We were so close!
I still don't understand.
I didn't understand that one.
Oh my god.
There was no eight.
We were actually one off.
I was...
Oh my god!
Oh, it would have been the fastest clear run of all time.
It really would have been...
I just didn't understand the password shit.
It was a really good run.
It really was.
What?
Oh.
We would have been We would have been gamers We would have
been gaming We would have had the fastest ones Of our lives
Okay What
Oh We're supposed to find something
I don't think it's mine Sweeper I'm supposed to think we're
supposed to find We agree
That scared me That actually scared me Oh no Oh this is my
worst one That actually scared me I was not expecting it Oh
yes Okay it's in here somewhere I could tell Oh my Oh my
god.
Okay, it's in here.
And then it's in here.
It's in this fucking box.
And then it's in this box.
Bam!
There we go.
Wait, what?
Oh!
Okay, we are.
Alright, so we're playing creating game right now.
Okay, we'll put him here.
And then...
And we'll release him here.
Alright.
I can't believe I fumbled the fastest clear possible.
I can't believe I fumbled it in truly dokey fashion.
I actually fumbled it.
I'm so sad that it would have been a new world wrecked!
I just didn't understand.
I was so confused.
Where is he?
There we go.
I could shoot things.
What?
Oh.
There we go.
Agreed.
Okay, I could have typed it faster, but my fucking sandwich
was in front of me.
my keyboard okay what oh my god i'm playing tetris right now
okay all right it's tetris time
that's fine this is terrible this is not fine actually it
gave me the fucking two spinning blocks really
really of all the blocks you could give me it's two spinnies
it's the t-spin blocks really you could give me any blocks
but you had to give me the t-spins oh my god this is over
it's not even like like smooth too i'm not raging i'm just
very excited guys there's a difference Okay, maybe this is
enough of a platform that I made for myself.
This cursed ass platform.
Oh my god, do not ruin this for me.
There we go.
There.
No!
It's over.
It's already over.
I said don't ruin it.
And it ruined it.
Okay, that's fine.
I can find it.
Disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree,
disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree,
disagree, disagree, disagree, what?
Where could it be?
I...
Everything says disagree!
I missed it!
Misagreed.
Oh, there you go.
Agreed.
It's literally right there.
Where are you hiding, little one?
Wait, oh, there he is.
Okay, this one.
I find you.
I found you.
What?
I was confused.
I was like, oh, okay, I pushed it.
What do I do?
Disagree?
I just disagree, right?
All right, we should put this all over here.
Oh, man, I'm so sad.
That would have been a god run.
That would have been, What could have been...
What could have been...
Truly the run of all time!
I'm still thinking about it, guys.
I don't even know how that game was played.
No, Doki, go quicker.
Remember when she was about to beat the game on her first
try?
I remember.
All right, we'll take it more slow this time.
There it is.
What?
Am I turning it the wrong way?
What other way can I turn this?
I'm spinning it?
Speed?
I'm still spinning it?
How much faster can I go?
Am I spinning it the right wrong way?
I'm spinning it the other way.
Lefty, righty.
Oh my god.
Spin!
Guys, I don't think we're going to make it.
I couldn't understand.
I just went and disagreed.
I couldn't figure it out, so I'll disagree.
Disagree.
I didn't know.
I was so confused.
I X'd it out.
Because it wouldn't show up.
Oh.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
All right.
Oh my god, not you again.
Not you again.
Alright.
We're gonna be a little more strategic with this.
Oh my god.
Just...
Alright.
There we go.
It is possible.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
We don't need that.
Okay.
We're just going to be a little bit more...
We're building a foundation, guys.
Oh, my God.
It's fine.
We're building a foundation here.
It's like a house.
Oh, my God.
You fucker.
There we go.
Foundation built.
Okay, give me this.
It's here somewhere.
I disagree.
Disagree.
Where are you?
Oh my god, I can't find you!
It moved!
Oh my god, there's so many moving.
Where are you?
Where did he go?
I'm so where did he go?
I'm there.
I saw it.
You saw where?
Where did you see it?
Wait.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
I found him.
Oh, okay.
This is fine.
Agra.
Agri.
I was like, yo, why would you do this to me?
Why would you do this?
I'm not a robot.
I was like, he's there, right?
I don't know.
That's disagree.
Oh.
There he go.
There he is.
All right.
That caught me.
Oh my god, it's those phone games.
Wait, what?
I messed up.
I actually think I can make it.
There's no way left to agree.
No!
I didn't make it.
I can't believe I didn't make it.
Oh my god, that's actually evil That's so evil He's like,
what about me?
What?
Confirmed Okay
Oh my god, how is there more things going on here?
Oh my god Alright, last one, last two There we go We got it
I'm like, how is there new more new things in this game?
Disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree,
disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree, disagree,
disagree, oh, agree.
What?
Oh.
drawing a line to agree oh my god quick i need more agrees
there you
go if i let these guys out and then go like and then
and then i'll put these guys here
and There we go.
I figured it out.
I did not figure it out.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, you did.
I...
Oh, my God.
I don't understand this one.
I'm spinning it.
Guys, how do we do this one?
I don't understand.
I...
spin, but yet nothing comes out.
It's the run killer.
Users said it was fun, it was interesting, it helps increase
their motivations to continue.
I can't write on anything.
Oh, the righty-tidy, lefty, loosey?
Alright, I'm loosing it up.
You're saying it's getting loose, guys?
Oh, it's...
Oh my god, this is an actual run killer.
That's so messed up.
That's actually so messed up that that's a run killer.
Okay.
Yes.
I have read it.
Oh, there we go.
We got it.
Okay.
No.
No, I'm not.
Yes.
No.
Okay, yes.
Leave.
Why is the three second rule to then choose a carefully
draw?
Why is it when you're why do emails, why do friends you
start with hey, listen, why do you miss this problem?
I'll get back to you later.
Why do friends do you have to erase you?
There you go.
Oh, there you go.
Yes, thank God.
Thank God we got him.
He's dead.
gone forever
agree oh my god oh my god I'm back in the fucking 2000s it's
a fucking 2000 wallpaper infamous maze oh my god that's a
rat oh yeah I thought the rat would kill me The rat was
going to kill me.
Okay, thank God.
The rat.
Oh, my God.
Another pachinko.
How much more pachinko am I going to get?
No!
Okay, nice.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
Pachinko.
No, no, no, no.
Okay.
Pachinko.
So much pachinko.
It's all pachinko.
Oh, that was close.
That was close.
That was really close.
Okay.
I got it.
Oh.
I'll get it.
My God.
Oh my, oh my, oh my god, that is not fair.
It's just debris everywhere.
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
She made it.
You made it.
You're free now, sweet child.
You're free.
No!
No, it's...
Okay.
Guys, I don't know.
Oh, boy!
Wait, wait!
We have two stars!
Wait,
eight, zero!
It almost worked!
It almost worked, guys!
Oh god.
I mean
I could but like you know what I mean it was it was so fast
that I was like which one was it at the end it was so fast
you don't understand it was so very fast I was trying to
figure out which one it is I can't believe we all but we got
it because of boob because of boob oh no not again we almost
got it oh
no no no it's too fast always put faith in boop okay
all right
Below us.
It's still below us.
It's above us.
It's to the left.
It's below me.
It's above.
Oh, there he is.
Find you.
There you are.
I found you.
Yes.
Leave.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, thank God you're here.
You're here.
There we go.
We were so close there.
Pachiko!
Oh, no.
No, no.
Don't do this to me.
Rushdie.
Oh, my God.
This is terrible.
Pachiko.
There's so much gamba I rely on the life of gamba Okay, 50
No, no 80 Minus 20, that's fine That's fine And then divided
by 2 Okay Okay Okay, nothing?
Alright, that's cool Oh, okay, that's cool Minus 20
60 60 minus 10 oh minus 480 okay that's fine that's fine my
pachinko luck is not it oh don't don't don't guys i don't
think gambles for me right minus 8 okay that's fine that's
fine it's just minus 10 i'm like stuck in this eternal hell
right now no no no oh oh my god oh my god my god it's shot
me right through never give up
oh thank god okay will to agree agreed
oh my god okay that's fine that's fine it's just the
beginning
i just didn't read it okay i just gotta start reading
the moment i start reading it it'll all click want to give
you money let me agree let me sell my soul to you what
disagree disagree how did i miss it it's all disagree
disagree oh my god it's right here it's right here i fucking
i I hate that one the most.
That one sucks.
That one, at least this one.
It's like one of them walking around.
But the other one is like, oh.
Oh, nice.
First shot.
Like, how?
Oh.
That's messed up.
I will say that one is the most fucked up.
up one.
I can't believe my first try of this game was like the
kindness it's ever been to me.
Like,
it's the kindness it's ever been to me.
There we go.
Oh.
The first taste is free.
It really was.
I just didn't understand the password at first.
I didn't realize I didn't realize
This is hell.
Oh my.
Please, I just need to make...
Come on.
Okay.
I don't understand.
I was so good at it before.
okay okay i got slow and serious
okay now it moves you can't be doing this to me i finally
got the rhythm oh my god okay thank you okay there you go
all right i like got the rhythm and then it did that to me
it was so messed up
okay knock knock okay there's disagree
I assume there's okay there you go okay I was gonna say
please let only be one oh my god okay what am I supposed to
do here
okay it's literally just Tetris okay that's fine I play
Tetris
I'll put the ones I don't need here
okay I think I messed it up I think I already messed it up,
guys.
It's okay.
It's fine.
They gave me a couple of sticks for this.
There we go.
That's fine.
Give me too many sticks.
Oh, no.
I fucked it up already.
I already fucked it up.
They gave me too many sticks, guys.
They gave me too many sticks.
There you go.
What the fuck?
Excuse me?
Oh, it's over.
It's over.
I don't know how to construct.
I don't know how to salvage this.
It's over.
It's already over.
I already messed it up.
Like, I died down.
I know when to quit.
I know.
I know when it's time to clock out.
I understand now why this took people 10 hours.
I told you guys.
It's just all.
RNG.
It's just all RNG.
I had the luckiest run of my life.
I got why is this?
Release!
There you go.
Why?
Oh my god.
There you go.
That should be perfect.
I swear to God this thing's blocked.
it?
I swear to God.
I swear.
That's right.
Get over here.
Get over.
I was like, get your ass over here.
All right.
Oh, I hate this one.
Oh, my God.
This one's hard.
I'm good.
Like, head-on coordination, even this one is frustrating
because it's so tiny.
There we go.
This one's so hard.
Like, what?
What?
Okay, I got so confused.
I was like, what am I fucking doing here?
He's like, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
I'm like, what is he trying to sell me?
Oh, God, not this one.
Get out of here Do I do it faster slow?
No, no!
I don't remember how How did I do it before?
How did it work?
Oh, no This needs to be at the end
Oh, no
Oh, yay!
Alright, yeah.
I'll select that.
I'll just do an outline of all of this.
And then...
Here.
Wait, that contained a green soda?
Wait, does the glass count?
Does like this count?
Or no?
Like, does it count down here?
No?
It's just this, right?
What?
I don't know if this part can't I'm just gonna add it in
just in case because I don't know if you count me when I lot
an outline of this
there you go yeah it does count in I knew it counted
okay this one this one one up nice I missed the easy ones
guys are you fucking what how do I make green oh and not oh
I have to make purple okay I was like what do I have to make
it's
Minus 30.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
It's fine.
It's almost there.
What happened to it?
Oh, my God.
Oh, here you go.
Agree.
17.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 1, 12, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 11,
6, 7, 8, 11, 12.
Okay, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
11, 6, 7, 8, 7, 8, 7, 8, 7, 8, 7, 11, 12, 3, 14, 16, 7, 18,
9, 19.
I got 19 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 oh my
god 1 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 oh my god 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
40 50 60 7 18 19 I got 19 Oh okay I got okay I double I had
to triple fucking check that's
so evil
it okay
oh my god no no no no they can't do this oh my god they
can't do this to me not toho after everything no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no a fucking course a fucking
course a
It would give me fucking Toho.
It's a fucking curse.
The one thing I'm so...
Oh my god.
A fucking curse I get Toho.
I'm so sad.
A fucking curse it gives me Toho.
The one thing.
I did not need.
And it's one try.
It's one try.
Oh my god.
Where is my butt?
Oh, the past one was actually one of the easiest ones.
Or my last one.
Regrets.
So many regrets.
It was so nice to me before.
It was so nice to me.
Okay.
I fumbled it.
I fumbled it so hard.
It truly was the fumble of the century.
No.
No!
Can I still grab this?
Okay, at least I can still grab it.
Alright, let's just grab this guy out of the way too.
I'm gonna grab this guy out of the way.
Put you out here first.
And then I can grab you.
There we go.
Oh!
It's fine.
We made it.
There you go.
Calculator.
Calculate for this.
I'm not calculating.
I'm eating my bagel.
You guys calculated for me.
One, one.
Thanks.
I don't
know.
Oh my god.
No fucking way.
What year is this?
What fucking year?
Oh my god, not these fuckers.
I was so bad at them.
No way.
I was so bad at these.
Oh.
One of them will hit, right?
One of them.
Oh my god, this one's stuck.
Oh, guys, this is not looking so good.
One of them is actually stuck.
Oh my god, that's fine.
That works out.
It's okay.
It's fine.
It's absolutely fine.
Down?
Oh, there you are.
There you
are.
There you go.
Slow and steady.
Wins the race.
Agreed.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Yes?
Did you really read to the end?
Assuming that you read to that, don't lie.
Yes, yes, yes.
No.
Yes, yes.
So this counts at your agreement, right?
Yes.
What?
Oh, no.
Here you go.
Oh, it's fine.
Faster I swear to God if this is one life just like Toho, I
swear to God if this is just like Toho I swear to fucking
God Okay, here we go fine.
I agree
Where is he?
Where did he go?
It's right there, Toki.
Here.
Right there.
He's right there.
Don't you see him?
I found him.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
We gotta build a foundation.
This is not a very structural foundation.
But...
Okay, we start our foundation now.
Oh, God.
I'll just put him here.
This does not look very secure.
Okay, it's fine.
God!
please oh my god almost pressed disagree
okay it's fine i have a square now i swear to god oh my god
i swear to fucking god like how fucking strong is this
impact okay thank god we made it
This is hell.
This.
This is hell right now.
I'm in it.
It's not even hell.
This is purgatory.
We can't get out of purgatory until we agree to terms of
service.
What the fuck is this?
Lefty Lucy?
What does this?
Okay.
X equals alphabet number zero.
If it's alphabet, alphabet alphabet, alphabet, number, X.
Okay.
X equals, okay.
Model ID number.
You can determine if the model number contains the letter S,
prefer a manual version.
If the sum of the number, okay.
If the model number contains.
The letter S refers to the manual 1.12.
Okay, put the wires in the order.
Two, one, four.
Okay, wait.
The sum of numbers in the model is 18.
Wait.
That model in these, the two letters in the, okay.
Two, one, four, two, one, four.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, eight is correct.
What?
Okay.
Okay, five zero something four.
Five zero something four.
My god.
My god, which one is it?
Oh my god, it's five zero four four.
What?
Oh my god, it's Floppy Bird.
It's fucking Floppy Bird.
Ow!
It touched my...
I'm taking a bite.
It touched my toe.
It actually touched my toe.
Okay.
It touched my toe.
It fucking touched my toe.
It was right there.
My toe was touched.
And then it was over.
It truly was over.
I'm so sad.
It was literally right there.
I saw the finish line.
Here you are.
Oh my god.
Notting it.
Okay.
The stupid moving basketball net.
My.
Come on, yes!
Okay, I need to put my bagel down.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Not again.
Not the stupid pachinko.
Give me that 50.
No, no!
Still zero.
Oh, come on.
Give me anything.
Not 40, though.
Oh, come on.
Give me anything.
Please, I'm so desperate.
Oh my god, of course, a modest death.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, made it.
What?
Wait, what?
Okay.
Oh my god!
Okay, I get it.
I was a little confused, but I got it.
okay that's fine that's not fine that's not fine that's not
fine that's not fine that's not fine that's not fine i
thought i didn't realize there were fucking space obstacles
here
i think the worst part is that these guys
oh god get him out of me get him out get him out get him out
get him out get them out get them Get them out.
Get them out.
Don't let them touch me.
No, no.
Bad.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, oh my god, this is gonna take
fucking forever.
Oh my god, this will take me fucking forever.
I'm only, oh my god, my ship is crashing.
My ship is, I'm only halfway out of purgatory.
No, no, get this guy out of here.
Nope.
Get out.
I will lock you in here if I have to.
I will lock.
No, no, no, no, no.
Nope.
Not here.
I don't think I'm going to make it.
This is actually so hard.
Move you up here.
Don't touch me.
don't touch no go up go up go up guys I am not very hopeful
right now I am not very hopeful with my situation right
about now because oh my god up up up up oh
my god one second one second
okay i don't know guys
if i cleared this
okay this is promising i'm
thinking right now
could you put this here and then oh my god did it okay no
not again not again oh
my god oh please please please how do I do this I
fucking what i what's this
yes we yeah what yeah
i'm so good at this game we did it
we beat the game I won Optimal strat Optimal strat right
there I finally read the terms of service guys Golden
welcome to the tomato fire Welcome welcome
If I died all those times Doesn't mean I would have It would
have like I would have like not been like it would take me
back to the beginning i was so scared i was so scared to
lose another life chat would it it would take me back to the
beginning if i lost all my lives there okay thank god yeah
no no we're i wanted to see the end i finally made it i oh
my god yeah but you get Every time you did it, I did it
across the finish line everyone.
I fucking did it.
I saw the end That was fun though.
That was even though it was supposed to be a rage game.
It was actually pretty fun.
It was actually a really fun rage game.
Yeah.
Yeah, they named the game.
Yeah, they named the game after me.
We did.
I played the game guys.
I beat it.
Guys, I just took a little Just a teensy-weensy penalty
chat.
Just a little bit.
It was painful, but we made it.
I, yeah, I did it, guys.
Light at the end of the tunnel.
Yeah, I saw the light at the end of the tunnel.
I didn't rage one time at all, chat.
I just, I was just very, very excited.
I was very, very excited.
I didn't rage at all.
I'm on the leaderboard.
I can't read it.
It's in Japanese.
Oh, I'm going to call it here.
We have a lot of really fun streams coming up.
But I hope you guys enjoyed.
Yeah, guys, technically, it's not cheating if the game
offers it, guys.
It's not cheating if the game offers it.
Because, like, I could reveal myself starting to get sick.
I want to try and rest up a little bit for tomorrow.
For the rest of the week.
Oh, yes.
Dokilan is up, guys.
Yes.
Dokilan is now public.
I'm going to make a tweet about it.
But if you want to visit Dokilan, let me grab Dokilan real
quick.
And if you have, you don't need VR for the, you don't need a
VR headset for it.
But we have, you can now get into Dokilan.
You want to visit it.
Let me grab the link.
real quick yes i'll be making a tweet later today but you
can visit Dokilan right now enjoy i hope you guys all enjoy
Dokilan we are the sloppy sisters now are still trying to
figure out the perfect date and time most likely be on a
sunday i'm not this sunday maybe next sunday we're gonna try
and figure out uh next maybe next sunday to do our official
meeting crease at Dokilan but you can visit the town right
now and this is the word right now explore it explore it
meet other here i won't rest up like i said i don't know i
can feel myself getting sick and i want to make sure that i
take care of myself for today um to make sure i don't get
too sick later this week as always everybody stay hydrated
posture check get up and move around to get that blood
flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed guys you
deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys